hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
lecture 2 of William James pragmatism is
entitled what pragmatism means and he
tells us that there's really two things
he wants to attend to there's pragmatism
as a method the pragmatic method and
then there's pragmatism as a theory of
truth and of course these interpenetrate
but he does treat the method prior to
getting into the discussions of what a
pragmatic theory of truth would look
like an outline and he says that it's a
method for settling metaphysical
disputes that would otherwise be in
terminable so there's a few words there
that we want to attend to carefully
first of all interminable what does that
mean that means that it would have no
ending and so we can get into disputes
like this when we have people who are
talking about things that we don't
automatically assume to be metaphysical
but sometimes a court of social and
political and ethical importance to like
say freedom if somebody says I you know
can't exercise my freedom if somebody is
telling me I need to do things that are
actually good for me right there's
there's a live issue and it's one that
has some very clear practical
consequences not only in our own time
but really throughout all of history
that's a long disputed question and if
people just sort of dig in and say you
know I see things this way and the other
person says I see things this way and
they can't come to terms they can't
resolve the issue and the only
resolution there could be would be
perhaps coming to blows about it which
is not really solving anything in a
rational manner right and so we want
disputes if they're going to be
something that's worth engaging in to be
terminable to be able to brought be
brought to an end point and metaphysical
disputes so let's understand metaphysics
in a very broad sense as pertaining to
what is what what has being and so
metaphysical disputes are not always
just about what actually does exist but
what people say exists even if it
doesn't so whether witches exist or not
that's a metaphysical dispute even if
there aren't any witches or if we talk
about square circles right there aren't
any square circles that's still a
metaphysical dispute of some sense so
James gives this wonderful example at
the beginning about being on a hunting
trip with some of his buddies and coming
back and they're in an argument about a
squirrel and whether a man can go around
the squirrel or not and he says that
this illustrates how the pragmatic
method can be used so what is the
dispute so some of the people are saying
that you've got a tree and a squirrel
clinging to the tree and going around
the tree and the man tries to get to be
on the same side of the tree as the
squirrel he never succeeds because as he
moves the squirrel moves with him many
of you have probably had this experience
seeing squirrels in the park unless
they're very tame they always try to
keep some sort of obstacle between us
now the question is the man goes all the
way around the tree and the squirrel
keeps pace with him always being
opposite does the man go around the
squirrel and James says yes and
because it all depends on what you mean
by around if you mean that the physical
location of the squirrel and the
physical location of the man are such
that the man actually does you could say
orbit or go around the you know the
circumference of a circle around the
squirrel then definitely he does go
around the squirrel if you mean that he
succeeds in getting to the squirrels
backside and you know perhaps facing the
squirrel or something like that then the
answer is no and we have to make this
distinction and some of the people are
like oh you're quibbling and James says
no no this this is a perfectly rational
way of resolving it it really depends on
what practical consequences there are or
as he says it depends on what you
practically mean by going round the
squirrel and so according to James many
of the problems that we run into in
philosophy and in all sorts of other
areas of life have to do with not
realizing that we we have to focus on
practical consequences and he does talk
about previous thinkers having used the
pragmatic method without you know
calling it as such
he says there's absolutely nothing new
in this method Socrates was an addict
added Aristotle used it methodically
Locke Berkeley and Hugh made momentous
contributions to truth by its means then
he brings up somebody who none of us
read any more shad Wirth Hodgson keeps
insisting that realities are only what
they are known as and there's you know
if this is his game there's probably a
lot of other people that James could
have been listed as well why talk about
those
well his audience will be quite familiar
with Socrates and Aristotle from ancient
philosophy and you know seeing these
these terms Locke Berkeley and Hume are
these names we automatically think AHA
British empiricism and James will stress
that pragmatism is in fact a form of
radical empiricism going beyond to some
degree what some of the commitments of
Locke Berkeley and him would would be he
also brings up one of his
much closer predecessors Charles Sanders
purse who we typically associate with
James and somebody else that he's
talking about this in here John Dewey as
well as Josiah Royce and others and we
associate them in classical American
philosophy or the pragmatic movement
writ large or things like that
now person James actually had a little
bit of a tiff about the term pragmatism
and what it meant but we're gonna skip
over that here James is saying Perce and
I are basically on the same page and he
he summarizes what Perce is telling us
in an article called how to make our
ideas clear which is absolutely
important reading if you're ever gonna
study purse or pragmatism
in general and he says that purse after
pointing out that our beliefs are really
rules for action so that's that's worth
you know it's pausing on for a moment
purse is saying if we want to make our
ideas clear we need to know what our
beliefs actually entail our beliefs just
a sort of speculative or theoretical
thing or do they have a practical side
to them and purse thinks that even the
things that have seemed very theoretical
if they have any meaning to them they're
going to be guides for action in some
way so he says in order to develop a
thoughts meaning we need only to
determine what conduct is fitted to
produce that conduct is for us it's all
significance and then he says that the
tangible fact that at the root of all of
our thought distinctions
none of them are so fine as to consist
in anything but a possible difference in
practice now practice doesn't just mean
making boots paving roads you know doing
your taxes things like that
thinking is also a kind of practice
so-and-so is feeling so we don't want to
understand practice and too narrow of a
sense but he tells us if we want to
attain perfect clearness and our
thoughts of of an object we need only
consider what conceivable effects of a
practical kind the object may involve
and gives examples what sensations we
are to expect from it
what reactions we must prepare and so
then he says that now this is over
playing his hand a little bit our
conception of these effects whether
immediate or remote is for us the whole
of our conception of the object so far
as that conception has possible
significance at all and James calls this
the principle of pragmatism so this is
essential to to the pragmatic method we
need to look at whatever ideas whatever
objects of thought whatever claims were
making what practical consequences
result from this and so the the method
itself is as he says to interpret
notions by tracing out their practical
consequences let's come back for a
moment to the example of the squirrel
you could say well this is actually one
that doesn't really have any practical
consequences except getting your buddies
to say you're right or you're wrong but
but James would say no no it really
depends on what we're trying to say in
terms of the ideas the idea of around
what does that practically mean what
does that practically amount to a little
bit later in the essay he will use one
of his catchphrases that is probably
most closely associated with the
pragmatics method and the pragmatic
theory of truth the cash value of an
idea what is its cash value what can you
trade it for what is it actually worth
so we interpret these notions by as he
says tracing out our practical
consequences of them now he also
stresses differences and he tells us to
actually in two different places he says
that what difference would it
practically make to anyone if this
notion rather than that notion were true
if no practical difference can be traced
then the alternatives mean practically
the same thing and all dispute is idle
so if if around in this case didn't
really mean two different things then
it's it's a needless dispute right
there's no actual contention if we're
going to talk about having freedom and
somebody says freedom means getting to
do anything whatsoever that I want
- without any consequences and we say
what would that actually be like can you
imagine something along those those
lines and we could come up with some
cases but almost everything is
consequences right so no no real
practical difference there because it's
it's an incoherent idea James a little
bit later says that this is a really
nice phrase here we go there can be no
difference anywhere that doesn't make a
difference elsewhere so if you're going
to make a distinction between two
different things or you're going to say
so-and-so has a different conception
than what I'm talking about and that's
why we're arguing with each other you've
got to be able to say what the
difference is would actually amount to
and if you can't you're probably dealing
with something that is rather vague and
and you know kind of confused and not
really a difference at all
prime example this is in the wonderful
morality tale by dr. Seuss the star
Belly sneetches if you haven't read it
then you should look it up there are
these these creatures the Sneetches that
maintain a class and a you know
distinction between the commoners and
the elite and the elite have stars on
their bellies and all the rest of them
don't and now a guy comes to town with a
machine that can put stars on your belly
and everybody lines up to pay them and
they get stars on their belly and now
the elite people are like oh now stars
don't really matter let's get our stars
off our belly and that'll be the sign of
being an elite and within within just a
very short period of time they go into a
kind of frenzy and start running in and
out of both machines piling up their
money in this guy's hands as he goes and
by the end nobody actually knows who
started out as a star and on star snitch
and nobody can tell the difference
between them and of course the moral of
the story is this is a stupid
distinction because it doesn't mean
anything other than that that particular
social practice which can be upset very
easily the other thing that it probably
tells you is
don't give your money to people who are
telling you I'll make you you know
belong to this club or something because
he absconds you know taking the machines
with them and all of their their money
so this is this is a sort of prime
example of a case in which you know the
differences don't really make a
difference although you could say not
having the money in their pocket is
definitely a difference so he says there
can be no difference that doesn't make a
difference
elsewhere no difference in abstract
truth that doesn't express itself in a
difference in concrete fact and in
conduct consequence on that fact imposed
on somebody somehow some when somewhere
and some when so you notice all these
sums right it doesn't have to make a
difference to everybody at every single
moment in order to be a vital difference
but it has to be a difference somewhere
for somebody in some way at some time
and then there there can be some meaning
to it the other thing that he tells us
as well is that we want to avoid relying
upon words or concepts as endpoints for
our disputes and he says that this is
this is going against the rationalist
temperament of philosophy and that these
sort of people would be frozen out if if
pragmatism in fact became the dominant
way of doing things and he says that
metaphysics is usually followed a very
primitive kind of quest people hanker
after magic and you know it what in
great part in magic words have always
played if you have the name or the
formula you can control the spirit and
so that's kind of a superstitious type
of thinking and so a lot of people
believe and I know many people like this
that if you can just get to the point
where you identify something you
classify something you bring in a name
you bring in a concept you've now solved
the issue because you've explained it
all and James says no you haven't
doing that is not telling us much about
anything other than you can talk about a
word it says if you follow the pragmatic
method you cannot look on any such word
as closing your quest and here's where
he brings up the practice
cash value he says you must bring out of
each word it's practical cash value set
it at work within the stream of your
experience it's less a solution than a
program for more work and more
particularly as an indication of the
ways in which existing realities may be
changed let me give you a prime example
of how this often happens within the
history of ideas there are many people
who do what we can basically call
popular garbage sometimes also elitist
but they're all you know worthless
histories of philosophy where they
divide the world up into empiricists and
rationalists or they divide the world up
into Plata nests and Aristotelians you
know idealists and hard-nosed pragmatist
all of these sort of binary distinctions
that people get into something quite
similar in our own time is the diagnosis
of this or that as postmodern relativism
right where the people have no idea what
post-modernism actually means and quite
often our relativist themselves about
about things right
now a lot of people think that once
you've succeeded in either identifying a
thinker or some of their tendencies with
one of these slots that you would put
them in now you know everything you need
to know about it right that person is a
Cartesian get get rid of them we don't
need to think about them or that
person's in Aristotelians and I know
Aristotelian czar good so let's just you
know take them at face value well that's
just that's nonsense you have to
actually like read the thinkers read the
texts look at them carefully see what
they're saying you know quite often
there's a lot of different tendencies
going on within their their thought and
you know you'd also ask yourself well
what difference would it make if
somebody were in fact a existentialist
or a stoic or a postmodernist or
whatever it is that you want to throw
around you have to be able to say and if
you be able to say in a competent way
not in an imaginary you know let's
create a new monster sort of way that
we're all afraid of if they will say in
a competent way what difference is what
would be the case if somebody were to
become a sorry and existentialist right
so don't just rely on words and he also
about one other thing that that's very
important here as well he says that
pragmatism is a reorientation of the
person away from first things and
towards last things now he doesn't mean
teleology say in an Aristotelian sense
by last things he means as he says well
I'll just read through the passage he
says an attitude of orientation is what
the pragmatic method means the attitude
of looking away from first things
principles categories supposed
necessities and of looking towards last
things fruits consequences facts the
things that actually results so what
what takes place what happens if we
accept this
that's the pragmatic method so these are
all important elements of it there's one
other thing I suppose I should mention
he does bring up the the term
instrumentalism which is what Dewey
preferred to calling things pragmatism
and he says that theories become
instruments not answers to enigmas in
which we can rest we don't lie back on
them we move forward and on occasion
make nature over by their aid and he
talks about how pragmatism sort of
limbers up our theories it unstick ins
them as he says and so theories are not
something that are supposed to be an
endpoint themselves or a final
resolution but rather something that we
would use as an instrument to you know
figure out what it is that we want to
know and to solve some of the practical
difficulties and challenges of our lives
so this is the pragmatic method which
you can distinguish from the pragmatic
theory of truth
you